vamos ahora a calcular esta integral
verde que tenemos aquí y para hacer eso
vamos a parametrizar la superficie ese 2
entonces vamos a tener nuestra
superficie ese 2 que la vamos a
parametrizar con una función de posición
vamos a llamarle por ejemplo de una
función t que depende de x y jay que es
una función vectorial y esto es de esta
función se va a encontrar en r3 en el
espacio de tres dimensiones ahora sí
estamos parametrizado esta superficie de
ese 2 pues estamos pensando que los
puntos se encuentran en la región de
nuestro dominio de y después lo subimos
hacia la superficie de ese 2 estamos
pensando en la gráfica de la función de
f 2 verdad entonces nuestra primera
coordenada simplemente va a ser el valor
x y esto va en la dirección del vector
unitario y y la segunda coordenada va a
ser la posición de verdad que eso va
multiplicado por el vector de posición j
nuestra última coordenada será
simplemente pues el valor de f2 evaluado
en x y esto multiplicado por el vector
unitario acá y esto será para aquellos
puntos x coma que se encuentren
justamente en nuestro dominio de ok
entonces ya tenemos la parametrización
de ese 2 y ahora vamos a calcular quién
es cada punto n porque cada punto n
tenemos acá punto n que es justo de lo
que queremos calcular aquí perdón a
quien en nuestra integral verde y que
multiplica de s eso simplemente va a ser
nuestro vector unitario acá
nuestro vector unitario acá que va a
multiplicar que va a ser un producto
punto con la derivada parcial de t
respecto de x cruz la derivada parcial
de t respecto de y verdad ahora lo único
que tenemos que checar aquí por supuesto
hay que multiplicar por de a lo que
tenemos que revisar es hay que
asegurarnos de que esté bien orientado
porque los vectores normales exteriores
deben apuntar hacia fuera de la
superficie entonces por ejemplo aquí
debe apuntar hacia afuera más o menos ok
sobre sobre esta superficie lateral que
bueno eso ya habíamos visto que la
integral sobre esto vale 0 pero debería
apuntar en esta dirección y aquí en ese
uno debería apuntar hacia abajo correcto
entonces sólo hay que revisar que en ese
dos apuntan en efecto hacia arriba y
pensemos en que como cámbiate al
aumentar x pues simplemente se mueve en
esta dirección verdad y si aumenta ahora
la dirección pues aumenta en ésta
y si nos fijamos en en la regla de la
mano derecha si se acuerdan aquí tenemos
a nuestro primer vector tenemos a
nuestro segundo vector de este lado y
apunta hacia donde estaría el pulgar
verdad más o menos este es una mano
derecha entonces en efecto aquí en ese
dos apunta hacia arriba entonces tenemos
una muy buena orientación de lo que
estamos haciendo ok entonces vamos a
calcular esto
esto simplemente será cada punto el
determinante una especie de determinante
verdad ya sabemos que no es un
determinante como tal pero al menos nos
ayuda a recordar cuál es la expresión
del producto cruz y ponemos en el primer
renglón a los vectores y j ica ok y
luego en el segundo renglón va a la
derivada de t respecto de x que déjenme
ponerlo de color azul la derivada de t
respecto de x pues en la primera
coordenada sería 1 en la segunda sería 0
y en la tercera pues es la parcial de f
2 con respecto a x ok eso es tomándonos
la derivada de t respecto de x ahora
vamos a tomarnos la derivada de t con
respecto de ye y la derivada de aquí con
respecto del 0 la derivada de aquí con
respecto de yes 1 y la derivada de éste
con respecto de ye pues es simplemente
eso la derivada parcial de f 2 con
respecto de y muy bien entonces sí no
damos cuenta estamos haciendo producto
punto con el vector k
entonces vamos a ponerlo esto será igual
al vector k que multiplica a pues en
realidad no nos interesa saber todo sino
la última coordenada de este producto
cruz verdad porque éste tiene
coordenadas 0 0 1 entonces lo único que
me va a quedar es la última coordenada
de hecho tenemos quién sabe qué cosas
por el vector y menos quién sabe qué
cosa por el vector j
y ahora vamos a ver que nos resulta en
la coordenada k si tomamos aquí acá
quitamos este renglón y esta columna y
nos queda esta matriz que hay que
obtener su determinante y es el
determinante simplemente es 1 entonces
nos queda el vector acá y entonces
cuando hacemos este producto punto estos
se cancelan y simplemente me bueno aquí
faltaría multiplicar por x de a verdad y
esto simplemente me quedaría de a
esto sólo me queda porque cada punto y
es cero cada punto js cero y apuntó que
es 1 entonces ya aquí tenemos ya podemos
reescribir la integran la integral pero
en términos de la región de los
parámetros vámonos un poquito más abajo
y entonces tenemos que nuestra integral
que queríamos calcular que era ésta la
integral de r sobre la superficie s 2
escribirlo la integral sobre la
superficie
elegido otro verde que no en el que
estaba usando ahora si la integral de la
función r que depende de x y y z sobre
nuestra superficie s 2 por la
diferencial de superficie pues
simplemente como k punto n es es vea
entonces vamos a tener
bueno aquí aquí habría que escribirlo
también verdad la elca punto n ahora sí
por de s esto simplemente será la
integral doble ahora ya sobre la región
de los parámetros la región de de
nuestra función r que depende de x de iu
y en este caso z es f 2 de x de ok y
cada punto nds o dijimos que simplemente
era de a esto simplemente es d
entonces quizás esto no es una gran
simplificación pero ya está en términos
de los parámetros y está en nuestra
región de en el próximo vídeo haremos
exactamente lo mismo con ese 1 solo
debemos cuidar que todo esté muy bien
orientado y luego pensaremos en qué
ocurre con la triple integral que
tenemos
de este lado vamos a pensar qué ocurre
con esa triple integral que queda
pendiente para ver que son iguales